hi I'm Nick Gillespie and I'm standing
here with little Maddy Welch my little
league shortstop and the co-author with
me of the Declaration of Independence
how libertarian politics can fix what's
wrong with America we're doing ask a
libertarian day and the next question
comes from Julie borovsky saying or
questioning did you guys come to
libertarianism from the left or the
right Nick came through his by being a
lifeguard in New Jersey which he'll talk
about great length pretty soon I was a
Randi in lifeguard so I refused to help
anyone I'm just smearing those crap
pellets anyways I am probably an outlier
in Planet libera topia in that I came to
libertarianism not through philosophy or
economics or you know reading books that
kind of thing but from doing journalism
in Central Europe in the 1990s where I
was surrounded by kind of a class of
people strong stringent anti-communists
who consider themselves of the left who
wanted to fight against governments
because governments were telling them
what they could not listen to what they
could not do in their personal lives so
there's an anti status tradition and an
anti totalitarian tradition on the left
that has always spoken to me Vaslav
Havel who we write about in the book
it's probably the greatest modern
practitioner George Orwell people like
that going back from those and the kind
of anti-authoritarian us left in the 60s
and 70s were foundationally important
for me getting to wherever the hell I am
now and I came through to libertarianism
mostly through Reason magazine my older
brother had discovered the magazine when
he went away to college and started
sending it home to me I started reading
in high school and I was a longtime
subscriber and when I was finishing up
my graduate studies reason actually
advertised the job and I ended up
becoming an assistant editor editor the
print magazine and now working at Reason
TV and reason.com but my libertarianism
really at least the kind of
methodological libertarianism or the the
consistency and the philosophical
underpinnings come from reading several
decades worth of Reason magazine
you dodged the question left to right
yeah not neither I would say and you
know it's like I would have often been
accused of being a left-leaning
libertarian because I like books and art
and culture and movies that seems silly
to me I'm certainly not from the left I
hate the economics of the left and they
control mania there and I dislike the
reactionary nature of the right so I'm a
reason libertarian